[Music]
hey guys welcome back to office of
record when we talk about you whatever
we want cheers now that you put yogurt
in your vagina vagina make yogurt it's
were used infection I'm sorry you can
make kombucha from the bacteria of your
vagina you're welcome interested you do
it usually sorry so I'm on penicillin
right now oh [ __ ] I forgot to take it
today because I had an infection of my
wisdom tooth so they put me in a bunch
of passed along I was hoping was in your
vagina no but then penicillin kills good
bacteria also so it's [ __ ] up the
floor in my vagina
and so I went to the doctor and he was
just like looking around down there and
I'm just like okay and then he's like
well no yeah yeah and then he's like
well you see it's because the penicillin
[ __ ] up like the floor and there you
had to restore it with them flowers yeah
with him with I guess yogurt cultures
cultures yeah so you'll play he's like
he's like you just have to go get yogurt
aver and just stick it in there and I
was like like in the whole thing in
there so I learnt the baster so I was
like I was like wait like it in yo guys
I can't just some cheap yogurt I'm like
even like cheap yogurt each flavor is
like well I mean you don't have to go
pay [ __ ] cuz at this point I'm gonna get
a go-gurt and just like sticking just
you should get just plain no sugar
so that sugars no no just get regular
one and then so um how you do it my
girlfriend taught me was you take a
tampon dip it in the yogurt freeze it
and then just showed up there
why freeze it so it doesn't smear
everywhere so it hardens a little bit
yeah so merrily yogurt helps your vagina
to home I started to finish my pencil
yeah okay it's because it has probiotics
probiotics in the eye do you know what
your [ __ ] smells like right now you
can't just like yogurt I have like peach
[ __ ] written arms kidding I would have
gotten [ __ ] yacht cold man that
[ __ ] has a lot of
there's a lot of probiotic old man it's
like a shot glass of yogurt you ever had
so [ __ ] I love it no it's uh how many
times do you have to put yogurt um I
don't know he just said just do it like
once wherever girl I think he was
flirting with you I think he was just
trying to go girl go girls you like your
boys I'll give you some yogurts it's
gonna take like five minutes
yes I do I have a tool that actually
fits inside did you know that the inside
of your cheek is made out of the same
tissue as the inside of your vagina yes
someone just told me that I forgot no I
was telling you that I saw this TV show
episode where that used the lip yeah it
wasn't it that's why [ __ ] feel good
yeah it's the same as a bagina that's
why I call it the mouth [ __ ] Oh tell
them the story about your friend that
had or someone that had to pull their
teeth out no this is the craziest story
video news story is not my personal
experience this is a friend told me this
a friend who was Becky Becky okay Becky
was dating this top shot like [ __ ]
dentist he was like making millions and
they got married with a prenup this is
pertinent to the story and he would
slowly yank out one by one of her team
leader on the farms near the time that
they were dating or married and so that
she would wear dentures because he
didn't want a TV [ __ ] yslow no they
ended up shaving her a lot of orange I
don't know so so they ended up getting
divorced and now she has no teeth she's
like our age but she has dentures why
would she well she wanted to find a
virgin what a [ __ ] no he wanted a gum
job [ __ ]
why'd he just [ __ ] grandmother I mean
he's got Sanders plastic surgery if you
make me sell the [ __ ] prenup I'm not
yank it out well how
Adar her blow jobs because luck she
clean I haven't had a [ __ ] teeth
feeling on my dick since high school
right a lot of girls learn how to do a
non teeth [ __ ] after that angel maybe
she did but it was very unattractive
because sometimes when I randomly browse
the adult Internet like you get those
girls who like like porn yeah like I'm
not even turned on it's like so maybe
that's like her yeah I don't know maybe
he's just got a crazy fetish oh yeah
it's like a tooth fetish because he's a
dentist so she can you imagine a girl
she's all decked out laundry all [ __ ]
beautiful
I only know the cup is accurate because
I would see my grandma like during a
[ __ ] dinner or lunch or something
we're all eating she's I got shot her
brain's firing by the way she goes
alright and we're eating stuff she's
like picking at it and then puts it in
there like this she had a [ __ ] glass
cup of water next to her bedstead and I
will pull that [ __ ] out when your little
boy though you'll give a damn it's like
funny yeah you don't know that's true
it's not gross that you water I didn't
know my grandma had dentures but now
like putting two and two together like
she did cuz like she was like always so
prim and proper like she always had no
polish on that she's never had chipped
nail polish she always had her hair done
always dyed and then she'd be brushing
her teeth we should just be like
hovering and like you could hear a lot
of like clang feels that way no teeth no
I don't know
so I just like yeah how does that happen
like how do you agree to that I mean
does your does your teeth start rotting
is that why you need dentures like why
do you need but you have so many
cavities I just worn I'd rather be a
[ __ ] three tooth and I'm never
wearing yeah i'ma just I would be so
rich that I might have somebody chew for
me in my mouth like a baby bird I'll be
like I want steak today chew alright
need to be it just have some weird
friend visually I doing that [ __ ] for
you alright
I'm not that I love you but not that
much I know that's where all the flavor
comes out watch gotta hook me up to a
steak and when you spin it like the the
leftovers it's nothing but just this
[ __ ] chewy as rubbish [ __ ]
flavours like you want some gum yeah I
eat juicy fruit and I get all the flavor
is only the first 30 do you think we're
always at last only like 30 seconds I
still choose the worst gunner I wasn't
allowed to chew gum my mom said it makes
your jaw square and my mom's super Asian
so she would give me half of a gum give
me two seconds to just kind of like lick
it do you have any siblings yeah I
design to nothing but yeah I'm dreaming
your face is so small I don't think you
should be where you need to chew gum
yeah I just you are used to fall asleep
with my god I wake up with it
oh there have been times where I would
to like winter fresh ice to chew or that
all the time and I would true for so
such a long time that would melt in my
mouth shame I made it I was making out
with my ex once and then he actually got
gum in my hair here while making out in
bed and we had to cut it off and then I
went to my hair stylist she was like
what the [ __ ] just happened here and I
was like oh [ __ ] I forgot about that so
just like a short thing just sticking
out and back of my head here what about
peanut butter the peanut butter trick to
get the gun how do you make out in a gum
like he didn't fall there just [ __ ]
stop and tell me like a my gum fell
outta just just bucket whatever I see
what happens like what Tommy did your
hair a hickey right
he's like ain't no one gonna want to
date her with a strand of hair missing
[ __ ] yeah yeah just one shining that's
what I like to do a nice cloud make out
with girls and then I put my finger my
butthole yeah big guy real quick so that
way after I claimed them knowing your
own finger went into your old butthole
I was like no way that'll be hilarious
though if you're like making out with a
girl and then you start [ __ ] slide
your face like this there's a real I did
that I'm a clamor and that's the one who
show up at work no one wants to talk to
you guys since you've been with Bart I
know calm it oh oh you got a do is not
wipe your ass that day and then get a
little Dookie to rub it on
my back because you'll smell like [ __ ]
everywhere you go and then people will
just be like uh-uh and you wonder why
you like which that's how you create
repellent and you can claim your
territory Oh got it I just play my
territory about leaving like bobby pins
all over his house bobby pin yeah that's
how you know all this thing did you see
that [ __ ] really is that how girls like
cuz I remember like I thought girls were
always forgetful I'll be like man no I'm
careful it's a joke that we leave [ __ ]
because we want other [ __ ] to see
that we were there so it's not oh okay
I shed a lot so like my hair is
everywhere so it's really hard to hide
be mm-hmm
especially when I had purple hair which
[ __ ] and I'll have has purple hair you
know my friend she was so [ __ ] dumb
she's like I think my boyfriend's
cheating on me I'm like why well there's
always girl hair and like girl shampoo
stuff and stuff like in his in his
shower and I'm like does he have a
sister she's like no and I'm like yeah I
think so hmm and it's just started
making all these excuses of like but
then this and then I'm all like nope
nope nope no it's cheating it's not hers
that's so much that would be super dumb
you did say she was dumb so imagine
she's like oh yeah it's mine the funny
thing is like she us like she suspects
it and then makes all these excuses I
was like why you kind of just you just
had a conversation with yourself you
know I used to be like that I used to
talk myself out of finding notes from my
ex-boyfriends phones this is really hard
in my head Michael yes it's like you
know it he probably downloaded from the
internet and then he sent it to his
friend and then another friend sent it
to him actually it just went around full
circle and then like now everybody sees
this like cam girls titties but it's not
anyone we know she has like a sign in
the poses for John
I'm the opposite I'm like so psychotic
in the opposite way hmm he's like super
honorable but then you make [ __ ] up yeah
I like make [ __ ] up you want something
to be mad about you fight enough I need
to be fighting someone almost all the
time oh yeah so I like find something
and I start a fight you like fighting
every day Corinna yeah so tiring okay
like I would say to keep my relationship
spicy I gotta have at least like makeup
sex like two three times a month you
gotta be on the same page though like
you gotta let them know like hey can you
just fight because like it becomes so
traumatic but it's not as passionate he
knows then he's like oh yeah babe I
[ __ ] okay you know yeah yeah her
fiance has like the nicest set no no no
one ever gets to see what he looks like
he has a nicest set of teeth ever I feel
like I'm in like an inside secret Club
because I know what he was before yes
almost perfect teeth when you walk into
the room and he smile does like damn
[ __ ] like turn the brighter is down
[ __ ] goddamn boo so nice he seems
like such a nice person that I can't
imagine him being mean yeah he was
really good no I imagine I actually
don't remember his face I remember his
soul okay
I remember people's souls I don't
remember their face or their names or
anything about that would you
cuz when when she walked it when you
guys walked in in the mornings the first
thing you oh you're like I don't know
where you have that what was it told you
know the first thing that she said to me
was hey Joe I used to not like you but
then Jess I love jazz and then since
Jess you're with Jess I like you now I'm
like it's not great that's the weirdest
thing to say to someone for the first
time but I love it that's awesome
I just I like the honesty now she's back
and she's here on news there you go
come on it's a fangirl over just more
but I felt like it would be weird
because
tecnique
I know more about you than just but it
was like I just wanted to say hi to you
so I could talk to Jess yeah she where
hey she walked by doin one of those
weird girls that like I like Backstreet
Boys not the main one but that weird
fat-guy you know wow yeah all my
ex-boyfriends used to think she was so
hot and you are so hot but it's like
really annoying to hear you know but
that's dope though because that
immediately made me like you yeah cuz I
was like yeah when people can speak
honest like that I'm like oh that's very
charming that's cool because you're not
faking it why don't go up and like lick
your butthole if I really didn't love
you I do that all the time I'm just
kidding no no no I don't do that no but
I there's a lot of people that do
there's a lot of people that have all
these like pleasantries right and it's
the same script same [ __ ] same thing
that I've heard I'm like say something
different yeah and when I hear something
unique like I [ __ ] hate you Joe
Dennis sounds like a real person
someone like the postcard or something
yeah cuz on pictures right like like
you're a goofy girl but like on pictures
you it's like what separates you from
other Instagram personalities like I I
don't know the real you but then when I
met you in person it was like oh this is
a real person you know we go to those
events right 90% of the people at the
events are still playing their Instagram
profile yeah you know to me like they're
still [ __ ] I felt so awkward I don't
know why I'm sponsored by that brand
it's gonna be weird if I just keep
eating in the corner so I was like
trying to talk to people but just
continue sucking my dick no I love it
your boyfriend you fit that world though
like the fashion and and DIY like just
everything right I I don't know how I
fit that but they like me so I'm kind of
blessed but like it's like what the hell
whenever I go to those like beauty
or whatever that kind of world
I'm just like why am I here what the
[ __ ] no I kind of love my social
butterfly miss because now every time I
go to these events I'm like okay who do
I know I know that person like I'll talk
to you for the rest of the dance catch
up the whole time here yeah yeah I
partner up when we go to these events we
always have a dependability exactly yeah
but you know what it is I think back
then you know I feel like back then it
was um when you meet people like they
had something different and unique I
just feel like now hell yeah I feel like
everyone's just mild as [ __ ] now that's
true there's a lot of clones of the same
thing yeah any of someone that looks
like this guy on YouTube already that I
knew ten years ago yeah yeah like I
already know like okay I know Tim he's
original now there's like 12 other urban
Asian dudes so many clones and copies
but when someone comes out of left field
and they're like oh this guy's unique
and this is a new person then I'm okay
like yeah I want to meet uh I want to be
like a fuck-boy like like a [ __ ] boy
pretty boy that's actually like
different
that's why Brett man rocks is my freakin
BFF and he doesn't know it I don't care
if he wants my video I just want be his
BFF I love him
that's it I'm sure there are a lot of
clones not like that there's a lot of
like blonde white youtuber that came
from vine that's popular for some reason
yes yeah like there's Logan Paul right
there's like 12 Logan juniors yeah when
we were at playlist I felt like I was
watching the teenybopper version of
everybody already famous oh I play this
is so weird I didn't like yep I was like
this is weird we're like a whole new
world like an alien world is so I just
felt like a pedophile that's what's so
interesting I can't I shouldn't be here
right now like why am I here how to play
pedophiles playground who's weird I get
a lot of people asked like oh do you Jay
can't hang out with like this certain
youtuber that
it fits that cookie cutter and then it's
really interesting because I realize no
we don't really associate with like new
YouTube very much I don't think so we
get very song yeah yeah I keep to
ourselves I think is new to YouTube
right now they're trying to play it safe
like the they have to apologize for
everything or they're just very vanilla
it is so bad I got [ __ ] for eating
chick-fil-a in a video because LGBT did
you tell a book you [ __ ] I love chicken
yeah pretty much yeah
and I ate it again the next week nice in
their face
gay people still go to chick-fil-a oh
it's crazy are you do speaking for the
game I just barks like [ __ ] yes because
it's so bonded you just had the night
okay wait am I crazy tell me I'm not
crazy you are recently I told a story of
what happened in a target parking lot I
was alone in the car and for some reason
my doors were unlocked these three men
they walk by and they're like rowdy
they're like talking loudly they're
getting down and dirty and I'm like oh
sit and suddenly I'm like kind of scared
so I locked the doors and of course cars
they [ __ ] make that noise as much
like they can't just silently look and
one of them looks at me and he's like
you know so I shared that story and I
was like I feel like would guys be
offended and then everyone was like what
we all know it's because they were black
[Applause]
frat boys yeah my butthole was ripped to
like the back of my head in the comics
because of that their race is asked this
one black people in the picture do you I
thought I was crazy and then someone
literally comments it this is why people
hate Asians and I was like wait I feel
like that's racist are you serious
but not you didn't do it but they
weren't even black no they weren't
they weren't even black look at
Guamanian Latino or like I don't think
they were Filipino but somewhere like
South Asia
oh my ocean yeah the family bait
automatically thought black people that
makes them races yeah but it wasn't no
even if it looks like three Koreans
Chinese like three Korean a dramas
walking by acting rowdy I was like lock
the doors
yeah old [ __ ] is it crazy Korean old
[ __ ] the craziness never fades yeah
hey Joey nuts do you guys know a lot of
Korean offices yeah I've gotten into the
habit of saying this for some reason
oh yeah but this like calm down bass you
know she has her own way with her I mean
if I'm like [ __ ] it's like this like
we're getting an insight into like they
give the you notice that she doesn't cuz
she just kind of edits herself yeah
what's your original [ __ ] look daddy and
all this I just like Knology Tony you go
oh yeah she stopped to you yeah yeah
doesn't cut as much I notice yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]